police in Las Vegas never believed the
man who carried out the deadliest attack
on American soil since 9/11 had an
escape plan and they are not ruling out
possible accomplices the local sheriff
now assumes Stephen paddock must have
had some help
but the gunman's motive is still a
mystery police released a timeline for
Sunday night's events they say paddock
fired the first shots at 10:05 p.m. he
stopped shooting 10 minutes later 10:15
two minutes after that officers reached
the 32nd floor of the Mandalay Bay
Resort and Casino the paddock was holed
up then at 11:20 p.m. officers blew open
the door of his suite with explosives
and found him dead on the floor after he
shot himself
vladimir duthiers of our streaming
network cbsn is on the ground in las
vegas near the concert site where
victims were shot vlad good morning good
morning the sheriff said he believes
Steven paddock planned to escape and had
explosive materials in his car he's also
skeptical a gunman acted alone more than
100 law enforcement agents have been
scrutinizing paddocks life to see what
could have set him off new video
released by the Las Vegas review-journal
shows the mayhem unfolding on the ground
shortly after gunman Steven paddock
opened fire on concert goers Sunday
night investigators have produced a
profile of a gunman at Las Vegas Metro
PD Sheriff Joseph Lombardo called
disturbed and dangerous well we know is
Steven paddock is a man who spent
decades acquiring weapons and ammo and
living a secret life s CBS this morning
co-anchor Norah O'Donnell reported
Tuesday haddock began amassing the bulk
of his arsenal in the last year buying a
gun just three days before the shooting
how many firearms were purchased in the
last year from October 2016 to September
28th 20
17 he purchased 33 firearms majority of
them rifles are you looking into the
possibility that there may have been
some kind of a mental issue something
that happened in October of 2016 that
compelled him to purchase those weapons
yes you are yes would it be uncovered I
haven't I don't have any information
haddock left no suicide note and so far
his motivation is unclear CBS News has
confirmed aviation fuel tanks located
about 500 yards from the concert venue
were a hit by bullet fire but not
penetrated it's unclear whether paddock
targeted the tanks police said had it
intended to evade capture and survived
but minutes after the shooting began a
hotel security guard showed up outside
his suite his bravery was amazing patek
fired over 200 rounds into the hotel
hallway hitting the guard in the leg he
remained with our officers providing
them the key pass to access the door and
actually continued to help them clear
rooms the weekend before the shooting
paddock rented a room in another Las
Vegas hotel the Ogden Police don't know
why but that hotel is near where the
life is beautiful music festival was
held chance the rapper Lord and
blink-182 were all performing there
Charlie black thanks